a second night of protests in belarus
the streets of minsk once again filled
with thousands of people
the protesters were met by security
forces who deployed stun grenades
rubber bullets and tear gas to disperse
them
demonstrators put up barricades
some were injured after being beaten
and others were taken away by the police
protesters are still claiming victory in
sunday's election
which observers and the main opposition
candidates say was rigged
according to the official results
incumbent alexander lukashenko
convincingly won his sixth term in
office
with over 80 percent of the vote there
are doubts about the election outcome
abroad
as well we're deeply concerned by the
belarus
presidential election severe
restrictions on ballot access for
candidates prohibition of local
independent observers at polling
stations
intimidation of opposition candidates in
the detention of peaceful protesters
and journalists have marred the process
and we urge the belarusian government to
respect the right of peace
to peaceably assemble and to refrain
from use of force lukashenko has
defended the police's response to the
protests and said those demonstrating
were being controlled
by foreign countries
these sheep are being directed by people
in the czech republic
the opposition understands nothing and
is urging people to take to the streets
in order to i quote hold negotiations
with the government so that it
voluntarily hands over power
as lukashenko moved to crush dissent
network data showed internet disruptions
in much of the country
with social media and news sites
inaccessible
but it didn't stop the opposition
supporters from keeping up the pressure
as protesters braved the police's
violent clampdown
to make their voices heard
for some analysis now we're joined by
belarusian journalist
frank villacharka thanks for being with
us we just learned that svetlana
giganowski
the main opposition candidate in the
belarus elections has
left the country and is now in lithuania
do we know
why she's gone there
we don't know why but definitely after
yesterday's talk
in the central electoral committee she
changed her mind
because before she planned to support
protesters from what i know
and she planned to join the protesters
but
three hours talk uh the secret talk with
the secret services of belarus
made her change her mind what did they
tell her i think
i think they they kind of blackmailed
her i don't know what they used perhaps
they
threatened her with uh with her husband
perhaps
with her relatives perhaps they promised
to not shoot people if she
flees the country we don't
know but definitely what we know they
achieved what they wanted
they divided protesters from their
leaders
and the resistance now becomes
leaderless
so the protest has lost its figurehead
it would seem
tell us more about those protests in
belarus how serious are they
i never saw it before that's something
absolutely
um uh unprecedented in the country i
must say that
uh i couldn't even imagine that
belarusians can protest
so uh broadly they happened not just in
minsk but in more than 30
cities i think hundreds of thousands
people took part
there were many clashes several people
died
lukashenka introduced army on the
streets and
special security forces the
alpha group of kgb was shooting
journalists yesterday we are looking for
our colleagues reporters um
there is no information since last night
about them uh one reporter my colleague
natalia
lubinioska from nasha neva was wounded
with bullet and she is in hospital but
her her condition is stable so it's not
just about protesters you know they're
shooting everyone who is on the streets
and it also could mean that authorities
are going to introduce something like a
martial law or state of emergency
and i would just add that one of
deutsche bala's own reporters
was detained shortly before the election
took place and is still
in custody i wanted to ask you is there
any sign
that president lukashenko is prepared to
make concessions
to the protesters
unfortunately no signs and opposite
he's um he's putting all bridges on fire
he doesn't want roundtables negotiations
he continues attacking the
the opposition leaders the media and
blaming everyone for
preparing the revolution he cannot rely
on the public support anymore he relies
only on the
on the on the force on the law
enforcement on the army
and he he put belarus in the pre-war
situation
and this war was started by him against
his own people which is which is quite
weird because he was always
claiming that he is the father of the
nation
thank you very much for talking with us
that was pranak viacharka
an analyst on on belarus
you